tinha um brinquedo antigamente chamava
teco-teco era os ouvindo Tiririca que
chamava você segurava aqui ele tinha uma
linha com uma bola aqui e uma linha com
outra bola aqui você fazia assim ele
batia em cima bate embaixo tec tec tec
tec tecitãozinho você começar
devagarzinho ele ia só assim ó aí podia
tirar de perto da cara ó que se pegar na
testa traumatismo craniano na hora hoje
tem classificação indicativa Ah esse
brinquedo não pode para crianças com
menos de 7 anos esse brinquedo não pode
para crianças com menos de oito isso aí
não existe isso aí é para as crianças de
hoje porque antigamente a criança ela
com qualquer coisa ela pega um Pedaço de
Pão ela dava no olho do irmão dela com
tanta força que sai dava me dá o pão Me
dá esse pão e dá o pão e desce pão
porque tem criança que quando chora
parece um carro de